and it was BTS big night at the Grammys
BTS oh you guys congratulation you guys
j-hope happy but thank you I'm gonna
celebrate
awesome et caught them backstage
the k-pop group took the Grammy stage
for the very first time to present R&B
album of the year growing up in South
Korea we always dreamed about standing
underground stage thanks to all our fans
for making this dream come true I would
be back so here are the nominees for
Best R&B element but they were also
caught on camera in the audience dancing
along T Dolly Parton's Jolin
[Music]
and singing along to hers hard place ET
spoke to them on the carpet about their
first ever Grammys you know we never
imagined that we could be here it would
always say it's a dream but you know
still can't believe it on this red
carpet you guys have one of the most
dedicated fan bases in the world hands
down I mean they made us they get the
wings they give all the opportunities to
us so I'm sure they'll be proud and
they'll be like you know you see all
around like they're here with us so yeah
so we're so proud do you have a message
for the Army tonight I'm yawns how's
mine now thank you for though or the
Army's you may not today I love you you
gave all of this you made all of us
we're so proud and so grateful thank you